attends attends attends parce que lui
c'est quand même lui c'est le roi des
donneurs de leçon donc on va voir on va
voir ce que va dire le donneur de leçon
sur ce voyage à Tahiti tu sais lui c'est
quand même parce qu'on a la chance
d'avoir dans cette émission voilà tout
le monde ne l'a pas tout le monde ne l'a
pas lui on a quand même la chance
d'avoir le donneur de leçon en chef du
PAP donc non mais c'est vrai tout le
monde ne l'a pas on a la chance qu'il
soit chez nous donc heureusement et ben
quand on a quand on a une pépite pareil
et ben les gars on on le laisse
s'exprimer non mais c'est vrai on a la
pépite on a la pépite du PAP ça dire la
pique faut mais c'est vous inquiétez pas
vous la piquera
pas une pépite comme ça le donneur de
leçon en chef du PAF il va nous dire
comment il il défend anidalg je ser je
serais curieux de savoir non mais Cyril
ce voyage c'est un fiasco il y a eu
plein de versions on est d'accord mais
après c'est un coup politique de la
droite avec une toute petite avec
une mais non mais non parce que je t'ai
posé une question oui comment tu
justifie il a il est-ce que il a posé
cette question c'est une goutte d'eau
dans l'océan truc ça ve dire tellement
pas du tout où je peux terminer ma
morale non mais la morale qu'est- j'ai
même pas terminé ma la moraletique même
pas terminé ma la pépite terminer sa
pH vén pépite du allez vas-y la pépite
vas-y la pépite c'est rien cette affaire
elle va rembourser son voyage la droite
se Terra sera battu aux prochaines
élections comme d'habitude et
l'association antiorruption c'est une
toute petite association c'est même pas
la grande association
gr pourquoi tu déig pourquoi tu déig
[Applaudissements]
l'association c'est des gens qui ont
quitté la vraie association et qui se
sont réunis voilà et qui font un coup
politique avec la droite mais c'est
rien mais elle va elle a déjà remboursé
le retour elle va rembourser l'allée et
tout le monde se Terra mais il est
Malonn intell tu veux je dis c'est
malonné Syb
tour j'ai envie de te
dég c'est P je vous en prie FA de dire
elle va rembourser ça veut dire que pr
dans la
main sinon on aurait ESS tout ce qu'elle
pasourss c'est une faute mais elle va
s'en tirer là vous en faites est-ce
qu'elle doit est-ce qu'elle va
démissionner est-ce que est-ce que ça
mais non elle se balade à
CH Oui à chaque fois j'ai voté pour
elle il a droit de voter il droit il
droit il a le droit arrêtez il a le
droit regardez non mais franchement il
vit avec des rats regardez-le non mais
c'est vrai regardez il a droit d'autre à
paratatouille dans un instant personne
d'autre il y a personne d'autre à
Paris Benjamin GB a desaques à Paris pas
tous les paris tous les parisiens votent
pour elle c'est pas un hasard non plus
merci merci ou
fait ça fait 2 he que tu parles tu as
pas rendez-vous avec dans ton appart
parce que si tu habites à Paris à mon
avis tu as plus de r chez toi qu'à
d'inviter
hein oui David non mais la la la
question qu'on pose avec Rachid hadti
parmi les questions qui sont posées
c'est soit le déplacement le voyage cet
escapade est une un objectif
professionnel et dans ce cas-là c'est la
ville de Paris qui paye tout l'allée
comme le retour soit c'est à titre privé
et dans ce cas-là c'est pour Madame
Idalgo en totalité alors là il y a quand
même une incohérence vous pouvez pas
dire au contraire à un moment donné elle
se dit elle est sub elle est subitement
prise d'un remord elle dit je vais quand
même payer le retour c'est bien ouais
c'est ça ouais c'est quand même bizarre
non vous pouvez pas dire que vous êtes
pas troublé mais on se répend en France
che chez nos voisins scandinav en
Allemagne ou en Grande-Bretagne
ÉtatsUnis mais l'affaire serait déjà
régléeit une démission démission ah
ouais exactement bien sûr fou quoi les
mecs c'est sûr dans les dans les autres
pays mais il y a y a que chez nous qu'on
voit ça vous êtes F quoi fam non mais
toi toi toi g tu es quand même tu es
quand même le garant quand même
de de la
merde non mais quand même dans les
autres pays les gens mis en examen de
tout bord politique il démissionne pas
ici pas en France vous le savez bien la
France c'est différent mais là il y a
même pas d'action judiciaire encore il y
a une plainte déposée quand il y a une
plainte déposée ici on dit toujours
présomption d'inoc mais là elle l'a dit
ellemême qu'elle avait qu' qu'elle avait
payé qu'elle payé avec l'AM
par tu t'r toujours avec la morale en
fait c'est toujours à de vitesse pour
toi y a
desations je connais il doit avoir un
intér s tu vas faire un élevage de r
dans
Paris inérê s tuas un intérêt je te
connais quel intérêt que j'ai j'ai
toujours voté mais j'ai toujours voté
pour elle je vous ai toujours dit pour
qui je v j'ai un intérêt de quoi mais
arrêtez en de la
ville'
il y a un truc il a dû demander un truc
à l'Amérique de Paris une autorisation
un truc autorisation de quoi arrête un
peu moi j'aimais bien leur demander
l'autorisation de
toterre non non mais non mais
franchement il est corrompu bien sûr
qu'il est corrompu Verdez
démission c'est quoi l'association non
mais c'est quoi l'association ass c'est
rien c'est rien non non mais voilà quoi
c'est rien ça aurait été ça aurait été
alors ah ouais çaurait étéur été ça un
activiste écolo non ça aurait été un mec
de droite
pour une histoire de costume ADM même
histoire la même histoire é un
scandale voilà
bravo c'est pour ça c'est pour ça qu'on
aime j verd vraiment c'est vrai est-ce
que tu te souviens de l'affaire de rugie
avec l'histoire des des Dîn et ce bah il
a dû quitter le gouvernement il a
finalement été blanchi il a dû quitter
le gouvernement pour une question de
moral par rien qui est prouvé encore le
gouvernement rien qui prouvé mais pour
qu'on arrête de la
faire bien sûr charrte de la faire chier
non mais toias ta moume tu as perdu ton
cerveau excuse-moi non mais excuse-moi
mais moumout mais en cerau excuse-moi
mais ver pas qu' a
plus tout le monde pr quand même
beaucoup de plaisir à toujours
s'acharner contre elle la preuve tout le
monde est mort de rire là c'est un peu
c'est la facilité de
toujour même pas comment fait pourir on
pas attendu on pas attendu comment fait
pour
tenirah
pas attendu Tahiti pour lui taper dessus
on passe son temps tout le monde a lui
taper dessus tap sur Paris auss non
st-ce qu' veut dire est-ce que je peux
poser une question à Monsieur est-ce que
je peux lui poser une question ou
monsieur Monsieur David on pe avec vos
actions exemplaires pourquoi
expliquez-vous que vous êtes battu à
chaque élection à Paris non mais c'est
non mais c'est une bonne question c'est
une bonne question parce qu'il y a des
cons comme toi qui votent pour elle
c'est tout réponse j'ai la réponse on
est des millions de comp alors mais mais
vous vous êtes résigné à la à la
victoire d'an dalgo la différence entre
vous et nous c'est que nous nous nous
résignons pas à voir cette ville abîmée
faut Rachid Dati he mer ou ouais je
pense que c'est la meilleure en
effet parce qu'avec desement commeel
arrête de dire pas du tout hystérique
c'est ta couple qui est
hystériqueve non mais tu viens tu vas
parler d'hystérie non mais avec ton
accoutrement non mais
écoute-moi c'est le croque for la preuve
oui non mais on a aujourd'hui une mère
de Paris en place qui passe qui passe
son temps à donner des leçons de morale
mais pour donner des leçons de morale
encore faut-il être exemplaire mais
quelque part moi je comprends que Madame
madame hiidalgo elle partte à Tahiti
parce qu'on vit tellement mal sous sa
mandature à Paris je comprends qu'elle
partte bravo
bravo vivement vivementashti soit MRE de
Paris j'espère elle le sera le sera moi
je vous dis prochaine élection je pense
qu'elle le sera vous verrez vous verrez
et j'ai le j'ai le pif pour ça c'est moi
qui Ava annoncer Hollande c'est moi qui
annoncé Macron et c'est moi qui annonce
là verra prochaines élections j'ai déjà
le Président je vous le dirai ah c'est
qui je l'ai je l'ai ça va pas te faire
plaisir donc tutoi allez ça va pas te
faire plaisir t fiches merde pas
continue à vivre
allez merci Dav en tout cas d'être venu
N